it is monday
unless you're chris rock because i'm
pretty sure he got slapped into next
week this was the hollywood version of
your drunk uncle starting a fight
ruining the wedding and then standing up
and giving a long toast america may be
divided but it was
kind of nice for all of us to come
together and say holy crap at the same
time remember 24 hours ago when we
thought timothy chalamet sternum was the
craziest thing we see all night if you
haven't seen it
i mean you have you have you've seen it
yeah
you've seen it
now late night tv is weighing in on the
oscar slap heard around the world
in the very very incredibly tiny chance
you haven't seen it we're talking about
that viral moment from sunday's 2022
academy awards wow
will smith just smacked out of me
will smith getting up out of his chair
mid show and smacking chris rock across
the face after he made this joke about
will's wife jada pinkett smith
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
yeah from the looks of that eye roll
jada didn't think it was funny and based
on the choice words will screamed after
the big smackdown it's pretty clear the
king richard starr didn't either
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i jane jump keep my
wife's name
naturally the day after the incident was
all anyone could talk about including
the hosts of late night television like
jimmy kimmel who famously hosted the
oscars in 2017 when the wrong best
picture was announced
for best picture la la land
yeah remember that the presenters
mistakenly said la la land instead of
the real winner moonlight
this there's a mistake
moonlight you guys won best picture oh
it's still so awkward now i'm a little
bummed because i've only now hosted the
second craziest oscars of all
time three years to enjoy that
a lot of my friends have been texting me
asking what i would have done if i'd
been on stage when i would have run is
what i would like
kimmel went on to compare the will chris
drama to that time kanye west crash
taylor swift's 2009 mtv vma speech
go taylor
i i'm really happy for you i'm let you
finish
even kanye was like you went on stage
and did what an award show
as for jimmy fallon he made a pretty
solid point about how bizarre the whole
thing was
seriously you know it was a strange
award show when it ends with a statement
from the lapd you know what i'm saying
yeah on sunday the los angeles police
department confirmed to e.t that they
are aware of the incident adding that
chris declined to press charges
like fallon said strange award show this
is going to go down in oscar hiskey
history is one of the most chaotic
moments of all time but this does prove
one thing chris rock can take a punch
stephen colbert gave the comedian mad
props for taking the punch like a champ
and he pointed out that he's actually
the same age as rock will smith trained
for months to play muhammad ali
i have met will smith okay i have spoken
to the man right over there he's got a
hand like a flank stake
and james corden echoed all that on the
late late show seriously though i i i
applaud chris rock for recovering
keeping the show moving uh it was
an incredibly uh dignified uh response
i'll say this will smith can't take a
joke chris rock can take a punch
a steel jaw unbelievable as for seth
meyers he brought the funny revealing
the big lesson we all learned from
sunday's big smackdown the 94th academy
awards were held last night and featured
the first live performance of we don't
talk about bruno from the disney musical
in kanto followed by an unbelievable
live performance of we don't talk about
jada
while the whole thing had our skin
crawling kimmel has the perfect solution
to me there's only one more step to make
this right and uh that's the comedy
central roast of will smith hosted by
chris rock
[Music]
you